I'm here to do what God put Jeremy
John's on this earth to do have
Supercuts quality hair and talk about
trivial entertainment such as movies
[Music]
anchorman 2 the legend continues
so anchorman 2 continues The Legend of
Ron Burgundy now and network comes damn
you know like we got this crazy idea
let's have a 24-hour news station Ron
Burgundy's like it sounds like
but I'll do it I like movies like this
because 24 hour news stations are so
commonplace to us now but there's a time
that did not exist so this gets to
touch on the Fagor one starts to talk
about it they're like that's the
stupidest idea ever and it's funny and
ironic and we know it works because we
have a alien of them so Ron
Burgundy gets his crew together now he's
in the big time doing the news in New
York the Big Apple first of all will
ferrell say what you want about it but
that dude commits to a role he's one of
those guys he never breaks character
he's Ron Burgundy on film he's Ron
Burgundy on set I don't think he breaks
character of Ron Burgundy until I think
he might have yesterday everyone in this
movie does such a good job at playing
their role and they have so much fun
with it you can't help but have fun
watching up Steve Carell is brick
there's something about Steve Carell
laughs in this movie he starts laughing
and he does that Steve Carell laughs
where he's just out of breath and he's
wheezing he's just he's laughing so hard
that I was laughing just because he was
laughing I didn't know why I was
laughing he didn't know why he was
laughing but we were all laughing
together and this movie has ridiculous
that you come to expect from a
Steve Carell movie if not a Ron Burgundy
moving it's like hyper reality kind of
stuff they crash a Winnebago on the
freeway no one would walk away from that
but they all do James Marsten's in this
movie he plays this douchebag who's kind
of the rival of Ron Burgundy for a bit I
say a bit because he is for a bit not
the whole move it and that's one of the
things this movie had going against this
movie feels like they could have done
the Peter Jackson split the movie into
two halves draw it out a bit now you
have two movies so much happens in this
moving at a point if they had just ended
the movie I'd be like ok it was a nice
full movie but the movie kept going and
it feels like 2/3 of this movie was
really good then one third of this movie
you're like who
the wrote that hyper-reality is one
thing but at a point it just gets
ridiculous it's like one of family guys
bad writers that wrote it's like the
last quarter 2/3 of this movie was
written by someone who was like I don't
here send that in the end of the script
was due last month not everyone's going
to feel that way walking out of the
auditorium it's like this movie divided
the crowd some people only like the last
third of this movie other people only
like the first two-thirds of this movie
so depending on who you are depends on
how much you're going to like this movie
however there is a good lesson in this
movie this movie shows what ultimately
newsroom touches on I'm a big fan of
that show I love that show which is at a
point the news became less about the
news and more about ratings and
entertainment it shouldn't be what the
news is about so I like seeing that in
this movie it's like someone was like I
like that concept in the newsroom and if
Ron Burgundy did it that would be funny
now we have anchorman 2 Sanker Man 2 was
funny Will Ferrell's great in the movie
most all of the cast is really good in
the movie I like the fact that in a PC
world this movies like no we're gonna
say that however in my opinion it has a
sloppy last act of the movie the movie
just drops off it ends and you're like
what was that it was written by someone
else wasn't I'm pretty sure it was
written by someone else
oh and although anchorman 2 is still a
good time no alcohol required there's an
anchorman 2 have you seen it what did
you think about it you'll like it better
than the first one or vice versa
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what you
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more and you stay
classy YouTube
you
[Music]